and this phone will take my talents to
South Beach and join in miami lebron
james has decided to play for the miami
heat rather than bear another season
with the cleveland cavaliers everybody's
piling on how could it dude with a
tattoo of the word loyalty on his chest
abandoned the mistake on the lake but
LeBron is only doing what more than half
of Cleveland's population has done in
the last 60 years he's getting the hell
out of the place did LeBron vamoose for
more money no though some analyses make
the case that because of Ohio's high
taxes LeBron can actually make more
take-home pay in Florida despite a
significantly lower salary than he would
earn in Ohio Clevelanders who make far
less though than LeBron should take note
and demand change in idiotic and
complicated tax system is definitely
putting your regional economy in a
full-court press back in the early 1970s
Ohio had one of the lowest combined
state local tax burdens now it's got one
of the highest Cleveland you need to get
rid of the Savior complex LeBron James
could never have saved Cleveland no
single sports store or entrepreneur or
bailout camp but there are definite
proven steps that any city can take to
improve life for its residents stop
paying for wasteful edifice complex
projects like building yet another
convention center allow parents to
choose where their kids go to school cup
cura cratic red tape for new and
existing businesses contract out city
services and maintenance check out our
series reason say it's Cleveland a
six-part documentary that shows what
other cities have done to succeed in the
21st century all without relying on
sports stars and subsidies to turn
around a town that was slumping for
decades before LeBron James was even
born
you